25 years ago you played a concert in  front of the entire world  [Music]  one month ago you played in Barstow  California for 40 people most of whom  were there for $2 taco night bill and  Ted what have you got to say for  yourselves  he backs on to each other and party on  dudes you were supposed to unite the  world and save reality as we know it  we've spent our whole life trying to  write the song level reunite the world  why can't we just go to the future when  we have written it whoa take it from  ourselves  how is that stealing if we're stealing  it from ourselves  [Applause]  no way how'd you like our song it's a  little on the dark side but you know  that's cool  [Music]